-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now we are going to
get to the news.
President Biden
is expected to meet with
West Virginia
Senator Joe Manchin today
to secure his vote for
the Build Back Better Act,
or, as it will be known
after the meeting,
the Build Back Coal Mines
and Nothing Else Act.
[ Laughter ]
"Time" magazine today named
Tesla CEO Elon Musk
as its 2021 Person of the Year.
He was going to go out and buy
a copy but then he realized
he'd have to pay taxes on it,
so it was, you know --
[ Laughter ]
Not worth it.
President Biden signed
an executive order today
that directs lawmakers to
modernize government services
that directly affect Americans.
For more details,
there's a number you can fax.
[ Laughter ]
Dr. Anthony Fauci said last week
that Santa Claus
is fully vaccinated against
the coronavirus
and that he also received
his booster shot.
Unfortunately, he put on
a few pounds during lockdown.
[ Laughter ]
Dr. Jill Biden said in a new
interview that being First Lady
is harder than she imagined.
Really? 'Cause the last one
didn't exactly make it look fun.
[ Laughter ]
Iowa Senator Chuck Grassley
complained on Twitter
over the weekend about DirecTV
dropping the History Channel
from his TV package.
It was only the way
he could keep up
with his high school buddies.
"Oh!
So, that's where
Thomas Edison went!"
[ Laughter ]
"Such a snob, Edison!"
A new film adaptation of
the musical "West Side Story"
was released over the weekend
in theaters,
and as usual, the Jets lost.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
We were so nervous
'cause we knew it was
coming out this year.
We were so nervous
'cause sometimes
we write jokes
six months in advance.
And we were so nervous, 'cause,
like, what if the Jets are good?
[ Laughter ]
And you remember, Shoemaker.
I said, "You know what?
I think we can put it on cards."
[ Laughter ]
Jimmy Buffett's Margaritaville
restaurant resort group
has announced it will launch
a new cruise line next year.
Though I don't know
if I like the idea of someone
that relaxed running a ship.
"Iceberg right ahead!"
"Hey, man, it's probably
more scared
of them than we are of it."
[ Laughter ]
Yesterday was former
"Price Is Right" host
Bob Barker's 98th birthday,
which sounded too high,
so I guessed $1.
[ Laughter ]
A lot of our writers
had their days free.
[ Laughter ]
During the pandemic,
there were less meetings.
Apple is set to release a new
iPhone software update that
includes a feature that detects
nude images to protect children.
And I can only hope
it also works on these.
Aah!
[ Laughter ]
So, people buy those and don't,
like, return them?
[ Laughter ]
"We just assumed it would
eventually grow."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, in honor of
National Brownie Day last week,
a Massachusetts cannabis company
created
the world's largest pot brownie
that weighed 850 pounds.
And to keep people from
accidentally eating it,
they added walnuts.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!